very pleased to see the transport
secretary Mark Harper joins us once
again in the studio lovely to see you
this morning
um please don't take this the question
the wrong way but but with with trains
not running across most of the country
as transport secretary do you accept
that you have failed in your job no I
don't I have two roles here one is to
keep the railway industry working but
also I've got to be fair to the taxpayer
there isn't a bottomless pit of money to
go into the rail industry and I think if
most people listening to your show look
at the offer that's on the table they'll
think it's very fair and reasonable it's
in line with what most people in the
private sector are getting we've seen
unite workers at Network rail have
accepted the offer the tssa are
recommending that offer be accepted by
their members and even with the rmts
very strong recommendation to their
members to not accept the offer to turn
it down to reject it out of hand we
still saw nearly 40 percent of rmt
members wanting to accept it so I think
the tide is turning on opinion about
whether these offers are reasonable or
not and therefore I hope the union will
look at it again call off the strikes
and accept what is a reasonable payoff
but just in terms of of the rmt from
their perspective it isn't just about P
it is about T's and C's did you or did
you not instruct the real delivery group
to insert Clauses into the the offer
document regarding driver only operation
trains without guards on the reform of
the rail industry has been on the table
from the very beginning and absolutely
can you just answer that question did
did you direct the railed Recovery Group
to Putin driver only operation into the
document to the offer document no no the
detailed negotiations between the
employers and the trade unions between
them the overall amount of money
available obviously is something that I
have to set so the detail is up to them
the driver only chains are not a new
thing they've been running since the
1980s and over half of them was opposed
by every single Union representing real
workers since if that is not a wrecking
amendment I don't know what it is well
over half of passengers that go on the
railways they're on trains where driver
only operation is in in place and it's
been accepted by um train drivers so
it's actually not I want a deal here but
that's why when I met the unions I made
sure there was an improved offer from
Network rail an improved offer and an
offer came from the train operating
companies that hadn't previously been on
the table so that's what Mick Lynch
asked me when I met him and that's what
I delivered it's a reasonable offer for
reform and pay and I think the union
should accept it you genuinely believed
that the rmt would accept an offer
containing driver only operations
something that they have consistently
approved I mean miklin said this we went
on Sunday to to have the conversation
fully expecting the blanks to be filled
in on P the real delivery group said we
can't do what we said department for
transport have made us put driver only
operation into this document and it
strikes me that it looks very much like
you're happy for these strikes to go
ahead you inserted something that you
knew the rmt could not and would not
accept no look quite the reverse I don't
want these strikes to take place at all
they're bad for passengers they're bad
for businesses like for example the
hospitality industry which is going to
suffer or is suffering as a result and
they're not good for the rail industry
going forward I want the strikes to be
resolved that's why I made sure there
was an improved offer on the table and I
think some of the trade unions have
accepted it you know you say about
people not accepting it that one of the
trade unions is recommending exceptions
unite workers except did it yesterday
and I think the rmt should think again
it's a reasonable offer on the table
reform needs to take place reform has
been on the table is he lying is he
lying when you said that he went in on
Sunday and the real delivery group were
instructed by the DFT to put in driver
on the operation as you're lying or not
I haven't been involved in the detailed
negotiations between the uh train
operating companies and the trade Unions
that's for them to deal with I I haven't
been doing that I made sure there was an
offer on the table which I think should
be accepted and reform of how the
railways operate you know seven day
working all of the other things that's
been on the table from the very
beginning I suppose I suppose at least
the rmt should be appreciative of the
fact that that you yourself are willing
to discuss pay with them in a way in
which and you know the nurses unions are
not being talked to about pay why does
Steve Barkley why does the health
secretary believe that he doesn't have
to address the reason that nurses are
going out on strike in negotiations with
nurses well first of all I don't think
there's a difference here I've been very
clear it's not my job to negotiate in
the same way the health sector is not
negotiating but meeting with trade
unions and listening to them I think is
very reasonable why is he Lots on repeat
that is the reason that nurses are going
out on strike they have a meeting he
doesn't discuss pay the nurses go out on
the street he's listening to their
concerns but on pay specifically you
know we've got for the Health Service an
independent pay review body that's made
a series of recommendations for people
who work in the health service including
nurses who we value absolutely we've
accepted all of their recommendations in
full the 19 pay rise that the nurses are
asking for isn't affordable I don't
think it's reasonable and it would take
money away from Frontline Healthcare you
don't have to stick to what the
independent peer review body suggests
you could add to it so when we have the
general secretary suggesting they're not
a single Brown Penny mall was offered
you could well have done so had you
desired to do so isn't that the case
well look I think we've got to also look
into account what is Affordable and
we've got to you know what they're
asking for would cost 10 billion pounds
that money would come away from
Frontline Healthcare so it's about
giving a fair pay rise and for example
we we value nurses so last year when
there was a pay freeze in the wider
public sector we made sure that nurses
got a pay rise they were the only people
to do so because we valued them we've
made a reasonable payoff for this year
which the pay review bodies have
recommended that gives a 1400 pound pay
rise to nurses which means for the
lowest paid nurses they're actually
getting a rise of 90 is it fear that
nurses starting salaries have risen less
quickly than an MP salary
and since 2010 MP salaries have risen by
28 you know and you will accept that
nurses pay has been reduced in real
terms by between 10 and 20 is that fair
well look we have accepted what the in
we have an independent pay review body
for people who works
you don't have to do what the period
would say well no but the pay review
bodies made recommendations about rides
in the past which we have accepted in
full which means the nurse will get a
1400 pound pay rise which is targeted
also at the lowest paid which gives them
a larger payroll than other people but
you've got to balance that against
whether it's widely affordable the most
important thing is that we get inflation
under control that's what's at the root
of a lot of these issues and that's why
we've got to balance rewarding
hard-working public servants but also
not having inflation busting pay Rises
it will embed inflation is it fair that
MPS wages have risen faster than
starting salaries for police teachers
and nurses since
as you know MP's pay is set by an
independent body we have nothing to do
with setting it at all you'll remember
that change was made back in 2010 so MPS
have nothing to do with setting their
pay was an independent body it's not fit
and they may recognize that independent
Peabody got it wrong well I'm gently
suggesting is that when it comes to
nurses pay perhaps they've got this
wrong well look they take evidence both
from the government but also from the
trade unions they look at Recruitment
and Retention they look at all of those
things and they make recommendations and
we've accepted them and I think most
people will think that what's been
offered is reasonable it's in line with
what people are getting in the private
sector I think most people listening to
visible think they've had a reasonable
payoff for and I hope they accept it we
will see what happens on that front just
one last question though Telegraph and
times have been reporting that there has
been a deal done with Albania which
could speed up the process of getting
people who should not be in this country
back to where they came from what can
you tell us about that well look I'm not
going to comment on specular relation in
the newspapers but look the Prime
Minister thinks that getting migration
under control is incredibly important
he's been working closely with the Home
Secretary on this and when there are
specific things to announce we'll
obviously announce them in due course
I'll take that Minister good to have you
on the show thanks for joining us